hey youtubers it's Charlie so zack
snyder's dropping some new stuff from
Justice League and we learned some stuff
about the Aquaman movie so this is gonna
be a breakdown so if you guys haven't
been seeing it they've been posting a
bunch of Justice League stuff lately
they're still filming Justice League so
this picture of Jason Momoa in his full
Aquaman armor is from the set of Justice
League and playing some underwater
stairway to heaven so we've seen him in
the trailer we've learned a little bit
about his character and he's like a
complete 180 from real life Jason Momoa
Jason Momoa is like one of the most
charismatic people that works on the
Justice League but you see him here
getting ready to bite Henry Cavill it's
the most adorable thing ever please put
Jason Momoa in all the films in the good
thing I think about him and Justice
League is that he's gonna balance Ben
Affleck's Batman out like you want to
have a version of Batman that is
hardcore but they can also be funny so
you kind of need someone else to be even
more hardcore than him so that is where
Jason Momoa as Aquaman comes in but
they've been working on the Aquaman
movie in the big news now and like part
of the whole reason for making this
video is that they've announced Black
Manta will be the main villain which
isn't so much of a surprise I mean he's
like the reverse-flash of the Aquaman
comics like his greatest nemesis that
always comes back even if he's not in
every single story so what I think we'll
see you know in keeping with tradition
because Justice Society has all the
Justice League characters in it and then
some of them will go after their
spin-off films after that like Aquaman
they will tease some characters that are
going to be in the Aquaman movie during
Justice League black manta being one of
them even though in the timeline they
push the story forward just a little bit
if they're getting their first felt like
when the flash gets his first film even
though we know the origin of the flash
he even already has his tech suit they
have to at least touch on the origin
story so that means that in Justice
League and in present day Aquaman will
already have this lifelong vendetta with
Black Manta
but they will explain why in the Aquaman
movie so if you haven't read a lot of
Aquaman comics you don't know their
backstory together basically it's like a
you killed my father prepare to die kind
of situation very Princess Bride but we
know one of the funny things and this
happens with a lot of comic book
characters is it they've read Khan that
story like the story between them that
feud several times because black mantas
original origin story is just way more
hardcourt like a little too hardcore for
modern audiences like there was this
story like when he initially debuted in
the comics where he got captured put on
this fishing vessel made to work was
sexually abused by his captors and that
is just like the most dark thing ever
and you have to imagine that a bunch of
kids are going to be going to see this
movie so they're like okay yeah we're
probably not going to do that in the
movie
so later runs of the Aquaman comic have
retcon black mantas backstory to make it
a little more mythological a little
friendlier to especially younger
audiences so the most recent version of
black mantas origin story is the
Princess Bride new 52 origin story where
Black Manta kills Aquaman's father then
vice versa
Aquaman accidentally kills black mantas
father in retaliation for that but that
wasn't his intention he wasn't trying to
revenge kill black mantas father but you
get the idea you killed my father
prepare to die
so lifelong feud very easy to follow in
while Aquaman is super powerful Black
Manta just has a lot of really high-tech
gear and super strength that's really
about the limit of his powers but here's
where it gets a little bit of fun
black man of course Aquaman always ends
up defeating Black Manta black mantle
and some pretty big wins like there was
a win where he actually got Aquaman
strident but there was a period of time
when he joined the Suicide Squad Amanda
Waller like visits Black Manta and
prison is like here's your armor if you
join the Suicide Squad we'll give you a
life back so the interesting thought
about this is you know I don't think the
Black Manta is going to be in a Suicide
Squad movie anytime soon
but think about this once they get a
couple of these big Justice League
spin-off films out you build out a
roster of villains like you have
villains in the Wonder Woman movie you
have villains in the Aquaman movie you
have villains in the flash movie they
could eventually be used in a future
Suicide Squad movie like think about it
this way Lex Luthor could be part of a
Suicide Squad movie in the future if
he's still in prison so here's my big
question for you do you want to see some
of the big villains from the spin-off
films you know from like the solo films
show up in Suicide Squad after they've
been defeated by each hero just remember
that they will cycle the makeup of the
actual Suicide Squad depending on the
type of story that they want to tell I
think there were a couple characters
that got shoehorned into Suicide Squad
this time but that doesn't mean that
future Suicide Squad sequels won't be
able to do like other really cool
characters that you
seen in movies already so let me know
which other villain like do you want to
see the reverse-flash and Lex Luthor
inside the Suicide Squad Black Manta
even King shark king shark is like a
smaller character that was in the
Suicide Squad before that they opted not
to do just because they wanted an actor
with practical effects in king shark
would have been a full CG character but
he actually looked really badass in the
flash TV show but speaking of other big
comic book characters so they announced
like Miss Martian ma Nell a couple big
characters for Supergirl season 2
there's some Justice Society legends of
tomorrow stuff that I need to talk about
so I'll be doing videos for that next
but if there's any other comic book
videos that you guys want me to do this
weekend just let me know in the comments
there's still a bunch of Marvel stuff I
know we were talking about a lot of Star
Wars last night so we got a bunch of
Star Wars got a bunch of DC got a bunch
of Marvel stuff in expect to see more
from the set of Justice League like Zack
Snyder just keeps like teasing stuff out
like here's Aquaman with the guitar in
his full armor happy Friday
and congratulations to this week's DC
giveaway winner you can use it to
help fund your quest to rebuild war
world maybe we'll see you on Supergirl
Season 2 eventually just be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details I'll just start a new round of
the giveaway when I post that Supergirl
Season 2 video so that'll be up later
tonight while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for
that Justice League trailer again and
you can click here to learn all about
the flash season 3 they just announced
who the black flash is gonna be thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight